der large hadron collider kurz lhc hat
mal wieder für eine sensation gesorgt
zum ersten mal wurde am cern in genf der
zerfall des berühmten higgs boson zwei
bottom quarks nachgewiesen wie bitte
warum das eine absolute sensation ist
und wie es jetzt weitergeht klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen ja
so sehen sie aus die data tipps des
vereins genauer des large hadron
collider kurz lhc hier sind 600.000
protonen kollisionen mit annähernder
lichtgeschwindigkeit drauf eine halbe
stunde laufzeit am lhc hier am atlas
detektor werden diese daten unter
anderem aufgezeichnet und im juni 2012
wurde in diesen daten zum ersten mal das
higgs boson entdeckt ein absolutes
teilchen durch dieses teilchen konnte
die existenz des feldes nachgewiesen
werden es verschafft alle masse die
eigenschaft von materie die die raumzeit
krümmt und so uns zb hier auf die erde
zieht das wisst ihr ja aus meinem video
über die relativitätstheorie gravitation
ist keine kraft sondern die krümmung der
raumzeit und die eigenschaft der materie
masse die die krümmung verursacht
verleiht das higgs fällt der materie
das ganze geschah am lhc eine der
größten und teuersten maschinen der
menschheit 3 milliarden hat sie gekostet
ein ring mit einer länge von knapp 27
kilometern ausgestattet mit mächtigen
detektoren in den protonen oder blei und
mit fast lichtgeschwindigkeit
kollidieren
bei diesen kollisionen zerfallen die
teilchen in ihre bestandteile und diese
werden mit den riesigen detektoren im
idealfall dann aufgespürt im laufe der
jahrzehnte wurde ein standardmodell der
elementarteilchenphysik aufgestellt und
am lhc und seinen vorgängern wurde
dieses modell mit seinen quarks lab
tonen und posen immer wieder bestätigt
beim zerfall des explosions in zwei
bottom quax war der nachweis des
zerfalls und damit des standardmodells
allerdings etwas tricky weil diese
teilchen auch bei anderen zerfalls
vorgängen entstehen
und das obwohl explosionen am meisten in
diese beiden teilchen zerfallen
nach dem standardmodell zerfallen higgs
boson in 60 prozent der fälle in diese
beiden quarks aber lhc koalition
erzeugen große mengen von buttons fahren
das macht es schwer diejenigen
herauszufiltern die vom zerfall des
higgs bosons stammen so kerstin tack man
vom atlas detektor am cern
wie also den zerfall des higgs bosons
finden künstliche intelligenz also
lernfähige algorithmen waren die
lösungen sie suchten in den daten nach
zerf allen bei denen auch jeweils ein zb
sohn oder ein velo sohn auftritt und das
ist jetzt gelungen
dieser nachweis ist ein meilenstein in
der erforschung des higgs bosons wir
haben damit nun alle kopplungen des
higgs boson mit den schweren quarks und
elektronen der dritten generation
beobachtet und auch alle wichtigen
erzeugungsarten dieses teilchens so karl
jakob sprecher am atlas damit wurde
wieder das standardmodell der
elementarteilchenphysik bestätigt und
auch die juka war kopplung also genau
die kopplung des higgs feldes mit den
geladenen elementarteilchen wie quarks
und laptop durch die sie ihre masse
erhalten
wir sind dem vielleicht größten rätsel
dass es überhaupt gibt wieder etwas
näher gerückt mit unserem experimenten
kommen wir dem wesen des higgs teilchens
immer näher dem teilchen das auch als
portal zu einer neuen physik gilt das
sagt elsen cern direktor für forschung
und computertechnologie so langsam
dringen die forschungsteams am cern in
einen bereich vor in dem sich eine neue
physik verbergen könnte wow
und jetzt in eigener sache wir machen
klicks und werbefrei keine briefe mehr
beziehungsweise ihr habt es in der hand
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal
mitglieder gewonnen haben schon bald
könnte sobald sein schalten wir die
werbung von jeweils einem video im monat
ab bis es vor keinem video mehr werbung
gibt werdet also mitglied hier unter dem
video und bekommt noch exklusive extra
videos live streams wie zum beispiel
nächste woche dienstag und noch ein paar
weitere privilegien einfach ihr unter
dem video auf mitglied werden klicken
tausend dank an alle die schon dabei
sind wenn er immer garantiert über
aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt
dann hättet mich übrigens bei whatsapp
dann umgeht er die bei einigen etwas
unzuverlässige abo box hier auf youtube
und ihr verpasst kein video mehr einfach
hier draufklicken und hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch darauf klicken
der large hadron collider am cern wird
zum super beschleuniger bis dann bleibt